прищі електроні декларації чиновники в
а заявилася і на сайті на царство вас
намагалися запам'ятовування корупції потім
запуску системи електронного
декларування доходів та майна дір
служба все в такому і виглядає неодруженим
пострив поважаєте за сідни експерт м д 65
зв'язок виду мови ви сертифікате нову
систему з поданням не поданої декларації
юридич ну начинимо і можна в них ну ти
поки раніше заходу не неправди виду не їм
теж суди фактично відпускають на волю
корупціонерів кольору шкіри завантажено на
дальнім кредитів мвф і адже рядків
безвізового режиму з
він хоче нажаль всі будуть у хор із 100
ват і ок аргумент йти люди в євросоюзі
і ки виступають продали б реалізації
візового режиму з Україною він і перука він
уват йому 9 у конкретну дату серб не
система мало за проти ти всі фони
метнулася а то що мій з мого конова ти
свої зуби в я зайнятий ці промови
не праворуч я сам з рук ти вибач хлопець
club закіні експерт це політики
батьки кому хочеш вище запустить і
систем електронного декларування
виразка за помітну сертифікацію і наші cs
прямо там ці у з я до фактичної дози
у офіційного києва на перехожого не я
реальних ставок українських чиновників